- Selamat datang kembali ke Memahami
Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum.
Nama saya John Watrous dan saya adalah pengarah teknikal
untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran ketiga dalam siri ini. Dalam dua pelajaran pertama, kita dah bincangkan asas-asas
maklumat kuantum.
Pertama untuk sistem tunggal secara berasingan dan kemudian untuk pelbagai sistem.
Kita juga dah bincangkan pengukuran asas standard dan operasi unitari dalam kedua-dua tetapan sistem tunggal dan
sistem berbilang.
Dalam pelajaran ini, kita akan perkenalkan
model quantum circuit, yang bagi kita cara standard untuk menerangkan pengiraan kuantum,
dan kita pun boleh guna quantum circuit untuk menerangkan protokol kuantum dan jenis-jenis interaksi lain yang melibatkan pelbagai peranti kuantum.
Selain quantum circuit, kita juga akan bincangkan beberapa
konsep matematik penting yang berkaitan dengan maklumat kuantum,
dan kita akan gunakannya untuk melihat
beberapa had asas pada maklumat kuantum dan apa yang boleh kita buat dengan quantum circuit.
Itu akan bersedia kita dengan baik untuk
pelajaran selepas ini di mana kita akan tengok beberapa
contoh yang sangat penting dan itu akan melengkapkan
unit pertama siri ini
tentang asas-asas maklumat kuantum.
Ini adalah gambaran keseluruhan pelajaran. Kita akan mulakan dengan model quantum circuit dan kita akan tengok macam mana ia berfungsi.
Kemudian kita akan bincangkan
konsep penting tentang hasil darab dalam, serta orthormonaliti dan unjuran,
yang berkaitan dengan hasil darab dalam. Kita tak bincangkan perkara-perkara ini
dalam dua pelajaran pertama, sebab kita memang tak
perlukannya, tapi sekarang kita perlu.
Hasil darab dalam memberi kita
alat matematik yang kita memang tak boleh buat tanpanya.
Kita memang tak akan jauh dalam memahami maklumat dan
pengiraan kuantum tanpa hasil darab dalam.
Dan dalam bahagian ketiga pelajaran, kita akan tengok beberapa had penting maklumat kuantum.
Pada akhirnya, apa yang kita nak buat adalah meneroka perkara-perkara menarik
yang boleh kita buat dengan maklumat kuantum, tapi untuk melakukannya dengan berkesan,
kita perlu sedar tentang beberapa
perkara yang kita tak boleh buat.
Khususnya, kita akan bincangkan
konsep fasa global dan kenapa fasa global tak relevan.
Kita akan tengok pernyataan
teorem no-cloning, yang beritahu kita bahawa keadaan kuantum tak boleh disalin secara umum, dan kita akan tengok bahawa dua keadaan kuantum
tak boleh dibezakan dengan sempurna
antara satu sama lain melainkan ia ortogon, yang merupakan had asas yang perlu kita sedar.
Topik pertama untuk pelajaran
adalah model quantum circuit, yang merupakan model pengiraan
yang bagi kita cara
untuk menerangkan pengiraan kuantum.
Model quantum circuit adalah
berdasarkan konsep yang lebih umum dalam sains komputer tentang circuit, dan kamu boleh tentukan banyak
model pengiraan yang berbeza
berdasarkan konsep umum ini.
Idea asasnya adalah bahawa
circuit terdiri daripada wayar yang membawa maklumat, dan gate, yang mewakili operasi
yang digunakan pada
maklumat yang dibawa oleh wayar.
Istilah circuit sebenarnya
agak pelik untuk digunakan bagi jenis model ini
kerana perkataan circuit
biasanya merujuk kepada
laluan berbentuk bulatan.
Tapi bila kita bercakap tentang circuit
sebagai model pengiraan, kita biasanya bercakap
tentang circuit acyclic
di mana laluan berbentuk bulatan tidak dibenarkan.
Untuk lebih tepat, untuk
tujuan siri ini, kita akan menuntut bahawa
maklumat sentiasa mengalir dari kiri ke kanan dalam mana-mana circuit.
Jadi kalau kamu suka, kamu
boleh fikirkan circuit sebagai menerangkan urutan operasi di mana masa bergerak dari kiri ke kanan.
Ini adalah contoh Boolean circuit di mana wayar membawa nilai binari, sama ada sifar atau satu,
dan gate mewakili
operasi logik Boolean.
Wayar diwakili oleh garis, dan di sini kita ada dua bit input yang dilabel X dan Y,
dan kalau kita nak tahu
apa yang circuit lakukan pada pilihan input tertentu, kita sebarkan nilai pada
wayar dari kiri ke kanan,
bergantung pada tindakan
yang gate ada pada nilai yang
dibawa oleh wayar.
Jadi contohnya, kita boleh
tengok apa yang berlaku bila kita mulakan dengan wayar input atas ditetapkan kepada nilai satu dan wayar input bawah
ditetapkan kepada nilai sifar.
Kedua-dua wayar input ini mengarah
ke dua titik di sini, yang mewakili operasi fan-out, yang bermaksud nilai disalin
supaya ia boleh dibawa
ke hadapan sepanjang beberapa wayar.
Jadi kalau kita buat ini, maka dua
wayar ini mengambil nilai satu, yang sama dengan satu ini, dan dua wayar ini mengambil nilai sifar,
yang sama dengan satu ini.
Di sini kita ada NOT gate yang
ditunjukkan oleh simbol untuk penafian logik, jadi
nilai yang keluar adalah sifar,
yang merupakan penafian logik satu. Dan sama juga, nilai
yang keluar dari gate ini adalah satu yang merupakan
penafian logik sifar.
Dua gate ini adalah AND gate,
gate ini adalah OR gate, dan kalau kita teruskan
dan sebarkan nilai
WEBVTT
melalui circuit, menilai
gate dengan betul, maka kita tengok bahawa nilai akhir
pada wayar ini adalah satu.
Jadi keseluruhan circuit menerangkan
urutan operasi yang digabungkan seperti yang rajah cadangkan, dan kita berakhir dengan fungsi
dari dua bit kepada satu bit
dalam kes ini. Tapi secara umum, boleh ada sebarang bilangan
bit input dan output.
Circuit ini kebetulan mengira XOR eksklusif dua bit input, jadi outputnya adalah satu
jika dan hanya jika tepat
satu daripada dua bit input ditetapkan kepada satu dan yang satu lagi ditetapkan kepada sifar, tapi itu tak begitu
penting, ia hanya contoh.
Ia adalah fakta asas tentang Boolean circuit bahawa mana-mana fungsi dari sebarang bilangan bit kepada sebarang bilangan bit boleh dikira
oleh sesetengah Boolean circuit, walaupun kadang-kadang kamu mungkin
perlu circuit yang sangat besar untuk mengira fungsi
yang kamu minati.
Ada gaya-gaya lain yang
digunakan untuk menerangkan circuit.
Contohnya, rajah ini
mewakili circuit yang sama seperti yang kita ada sebelum ini, menggunakan gaya yang mungkin lebih tipikal
dalam kejuruteraan elektrik, di mana ada konvensyen untuk bentuk yang mewakili gate-gate yang berbeza.
Kita tak akan guna
gaya ini, tapi kita akan perkenalkan
beberapa simbol kita sendiri untuk quantum gate yang berbeza, seperti Hadamard gate,
Controlled NOT gate,
Toffoli gate, dan sebagainya.
Sekadar sebagai nota sampingan, di sini kita boleh lihat asal usul
istilah circuit.
Dalam konteks kejuruteraan elektrik, adalah sangat natural untuk
berfikir tentang elektrik yang berpusing melalui circuit.
Tapi dalam siri ini kita tak
bercakap tentang elektrik yang bergerak melalui circuit, kita bercakap tentang maklumat
yang bergerak melalui circuit.
Dan sekali lagi untuk kita, ia akan sentiasa bersifat acyclic, di mana maklumat
bergerak dari kiri ke kanan.
Ini adalah contoh berbeza daripada
jenis circuit berbeza yang dipanggil arithmetic circuit.
Kali ini wayar menyimpan nombor dan gate mewakili
operasi aritmetik seperti penambahan dan pendaraban.
Di sini kamu boleh lihat contoh
arithmetic circuit.
Ia tak penting untuk kepentingan
pelajaran ini apa yang ia lakukan, ia hanya contoh yang
bertujuan untuk menyampaikan idea bahawa ada konsep-konsep circuit yang berbeza.
Kita juga boleh fikirkan tentang
circuit yang melibatkan kerawakan, contohnya, di mana gate mewakili
operasi kebarangkalian, dan kalau kamu rasa macam tu,
kamu mungkin boleh duduk sepanjang hari dengan bermimpi model-model pengiraan baru berdasarkan konsep circuit.
Dalam model quantum circuit,
wayar mewakili qubit, dan gate mewakili kedua-dua operasi unitari dan pengukuran.
Ini adalah contoh yang sangat mudah
tentang quantum circuit.
Hanya ada satu qubit dalam circuit ini, yang diwakili
oleh garis mendatar, dan gate, yang
ditunjukkan oleh petak,
mewakili operasi unitari yang dilakukan pada qubit ini.
Jadi tiada pengukuran
dalam contoh ini.
Kalau kita nak beri
qubit nama seperti X, kita boleh tunjukkan itu dalam rajah dengan meletakkan X betul
di sini, itu pilihan.
Sama seperti yang kita ada untuk Boolean circuit dari beberapa ketika lalu, kita boleh fikirkan circuit ini
sebagai mewakili urutan operasi di mana masa
bergerak dari kiri ke kanan.
Jadi kita mulakan dengan X,
kita gunakan gate pertama, yang merupakan Hadamard gate
diikuti dengan S gate,
kemudian satu lagi Hadamard
gate, dan akhirnya T gate.
Kita nampak operasi-operasi ini
menjelang akhir pelajaran satu, dan di sini kamu boleh lihat
penerangan matriks mereka.
Jadi bila kita lakukan keempat-empat
operasi ini mengikut urutan, yang bermaksud pertama H, kemudian
S, kemudian H lagi, dan kemudian T,
operasi gabungan diberikan
oleh hasil darab ini di sini, dengan ingatan bahawa urutan
pada dasarnya terbalik
seperti yang kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran satu. Kalau kita lakukan pendaraban matriks, kita dapat matriks ini di sini,
dan jadi tindakan circuit pada qubit X diterangkan oleh matriks unitari ini.
Kadang-kadang kita nak tunjukkan secara eksplisit dalam rajah quantum circuit
input apa yang kita masukkan, dan kita boleh buat itu seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dalam kes ini, kita memasukkan
Ket 0 ke dalam circuit.
Itu agak biasa. Kita sering ambil Ket 0 sebagai
keadaan diinisialisasi bagi qubit, tapi itu tak perlu.
Kita juga boleh pertimbangkan
untuk menggunakan circuit pada keadaan yang berbeza.
Kalau kita pilih, kita juga boleh
tunjukkan keadaan output yang kita dapat seperti ini.
Ini adalah contoh lain di mana
kali ini kita ada dua qubit bernama X dan Y seperti
yang kamu boleh lihat dalam rajah.
Di sini kita ada Hadamard gate, yang digunakan pada qubit Y, diikuti oleh gate yang ditunjukkan oleh
simbol ini di sini,
yang merupakan Controlled NOT gate. Kita bincangkan tentang
operasi Controlled NOT dalam pelajaran sebelum ini,
dan di sini dalam rajah ini kita
boleh lihat bahawa qubit kawalan adalah Y, yang ditunjukkan oleh
bulatan kecil yang diisi,
dan qubit sasaran adalah X, yang ditunjukkan oleh bulatan besar dengan apa yang kelihatan seperti tanda tambah di dalamnya.
Ia nampak macam
simbol untuk XOR eksklusif jadi ia masuk akal.
WEBVTT
Kamu boleh bayangkan bahawa apa jua keadaan klasik yang tersimpan dalam Y di-XOR ke atas qubit X.
Dan sekadar untuk kejelasan, ini adalah rajah yang
menunjukkan tindakan gate ini pada keadaan asas standard,
di mana kita anggap A
dan B adalah nilai binari.
Untuk keadaan-keadaan lain, tindakan ditentukan
oleh kelinearan seperti selalu.
Sekarang, sebelum kita pergi lebih jauh, ia akan membantu untuk
menyatakan secara eksplisit satu konvensyen yang kita akan ikuti mengenai cara qubit dipesan
dalam rajah quantum circuit seperti ini.
Dan konvensyen itu adalah bahawa
urutan bawah ke atas dalam rajah quantum circuit adalah sama dengan urutan kiri ke kanan
seperti dalam tupel atau hasil darab tensor.
Itu adalah konvensyen yang akan
kita ikuti dalam siri ini dan ia juga adalah konvensyen
yang digunakan dalam Qiskit.
Jadi untuk circuit ini di sini, kita fikirkan ia sebagai
bertindak pada sepasang qubit X, Y,
X datang dahulu kerana ia berada di bawah, dan Y datang terakhir atau kedua dalam kes ini, kerana ia berada di atas.
Cara kamu boleh fikirkan tentang
ini secara visual, sekiranya ia membantu, adalah bayangkan memutar
circuit ini mengikut arah jam supaya input berada di atas
dan output berada di bawah, dan urutan
qubit akan betul.
Kadang-kadang urutan ini mengelirukan orang, jadi pastikan untuk ingat
konvensyen ini.
Jadi bila kita fikirkan tentang tindakan yang circuit ini terangkan, apa yang kita ada pertama adalah
Hadamard gate digunakan pada Y
dan kemudian Controlled NOT
gate pada dua qubit dengan Y sebagai kawalan
dan X sebagai sasaran.
Kalau kita nak tulis matriks unitari yang menerangkan tindakan gabungan
dua gate ini, kita boleh buat itu.
Pertama, kita pertimbangkan Hadamard gate pada Y.
Kita menggunakan Hadamard gate pada Y dan tidak melakukan apa-apa pada X, yang sama dengan
melakukan operasi identiti pada X.
Dan jadi tindakan Hadamard gate pada kedua-dua qubit bersama-sama diberikan oleh hasil darab tensor matriks identiti dan
matriks yang mewakili
operasi Hadamard pada Y.
Ia kelihatan seperti ini, dengan ingatan konvensyen kita bahawa X datang pertama dan Y datang kedua, jadi ia adalah
identiti di-tensor dengan H.
Kemudian kita gunakan
operasi Controlled NOT, yang mempunyai perwakilan matriks ini, dan sekali lagi, itu konsisten dengan konvensyen kita.
Qubit kedua Y adalah kawalan dan qubit pertama X adalah sasaran.
Jangan takut untuk jeda video dan sahkan bahawa ini masuk akal dan saya akan berhenti mengingatkan kamu tentang itu.
Kamu boleh jeda video-video ini, pergi balik dan tonton bahagian-bahagian
sebanyak kali yang kamu mahu, laraskan kelajuan main balik kalau kamu mahu, gunakannya dengan cara apa pun yang paling sesuai untuk kamu.
Bagaimanapun, bila kita gabungkan
dua operasi bersama-sama, tindakan gabungan diterangkan
oleh hasil darab ini di sini,
dan dua matriks ini
didarab dalam urutan ini kerana Hadamard dilakukan pertama dan Controlled NOT
dilakukan kedua,
dan sekali lagi, ini konsisten
dengan apa yang kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran satu di mana urutan
pada dasarnya terbalik.
Kalau kita lakukan pendaraban matriks, kita dapat matriks ini di sini.
Dan kita kini boleh baca dari matriks ini apa yang circuit lakukan pada
keadaan asas standard.
Kalau kita jalankan circuit pada input 0, 0, bermaksud Ket 0 untuk qubit pertama, Ket 0 untuk qubit kedua,
hasilnya adalah keadaan Bell Phi+, yang boleh kita lihat dari
lajur pertama matriks.
Kalau kita masukkan 0, 1, kita dapat keadaan Phi-, satu sifar memberi kita keadaan Si+,
dan 1, 1 memberi kita bukan Psi-, tapi -1 X Psi-.
Tanda tolak tak
begitu penting di sini. Kalau kamu tak mahu ini berada di sini, kamu boleh lakukan operasi swap
pada dua qubit
untuk menyingkirkannya dan kamu
tidak akan merosakkan apa yang berlaku pada tiga keadaan asas standard pertama.
Tapi ia memang tak penting
untuk kepentingan contoh ini.
Jadi secara ringkasnya, circuit mempunyai tindakan ini di sini pada keadaan asas standard.
Bila kamu fikirkan tentang
apa yang circuit tertentu lakukan, kamu tak perlu melalui
penukaran kepada matriks dan mengalikannya bersama-sama,
kamu juga boleh jejaki
tindakan yang circuit ada pada keadaan-keadaan tertentu, dan dalam banyak kes ini akan
menjadi pilihan yang lebih baik.
Dalam contoh ini, sebagai contoh, kita boleh lihat apa yang circuit
lakukan pada keadaan 0, 0 dengan memeriksa tindakan gate.
Keadaan awal, yang
kita namakan Pi sifar di sini, hanya untuk mengelak nama
yang akan mengelirukan dengan keadaan Bell adalah 0, 0.
Kita gunakan Hadamard gate dan keadaan yang kita dapat adalah 0+ yang boleh kita kembangkan seperti ini,
dan kemudian operasi Controlled NOT membawa keadaan ini kepada keadaan Phi+, yang boleh kita lihat dengan memikirkan
tentang tindakan yang Controlled NOT ada pada keadaan asas standard,
Dan kamu boleh buat perkara yang sama
untuk tiga keadaan asas standard yang lain atau apa-apa
keadaan pun untuk perkara itu.
Kita juga boleh masukkan bit klasik ke dalam rajah quantum circuit.
Ia ditunjukkan oleh
garis berganda seperti yang kamu lihat dalam rajah ini.
Iaitu A dan B adalah bit klasik dan X dan Y adalah qubit.
WEBVTT
Kita ada dua gate unitari yang sama seperti dalam contoh sebelumnya, dan simbol-simbol ini di sini mewakili pengukuran asas standard
Khususnya selepas dua
operasi unitari dilakukan, pengukuran asas standard
dilakukan pada Y
dan hasilnya ditimpa
kepada bit klasik, B, dan sama juga X diukur dan hasilnya ditulis kepada bit A.
Di sini kamu boleh lihat bahawa qubit X dan Y terus berjalan selepas ia diukur.
Adalah agak biasa
walaupun kita tak begitu ambil berat tentang qubit
selepas ia diukur.
Kadang-kadang kita hanya ambil berat tentang
hasil pengukuran. Dan dalam kes seperti itu, kita boleh guna singkatan
gaya yang kamu lihat di sini
di mana pengukuran mempunyai qubit yang masuk dan bit klasik yang keluar.
Pemahaman di sini adalah bahawa
setelah qubit diukur, ia hanya dibuang atau diabaikan dan hasil pengukuran klasik
dibawa ke hadapan.
Sekarang bila siri ini berterusan, kita akan nampak banyak
contoh quantum circuit dan biasanya ia akan
jauh lebih rumit daripada contoh-contoh yang sangat mudah yang baru kita lihat.
Seperti yang saya sebut sebelum ini, simbol-simbol berbeza digunakan
untuk gate-gate berbeza.
Gate qubit tunggal biasanya
hanya ditulis sebagai petak dengan huruf yang menunjukkan
operasi apa ia.
Kadang-kadang gate-gate berbeza ini
dikodkan warna untuk bermaksud perkara yang berbeza, tapi
kita akan abaikan itu buat sekarang.
Kita dah nampak
Controlled NOT gate.
Swap gate ditandakan
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, Dan Toffoli gate dan Fredkin gate
ditandakan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Ingat bahawa Toffoli gate adalah Controlled NOT gate yang dikawal dan Fredkin gate adalah
swap gate yang dikawal.
Jadi simbol-simbol ini adalah
konsisten dengan idea bahawa qubit kawalan ditunjukkan oleh bulatan pepejal dengan garis yang menyambungkannya
ke gate yang ia kawal.
Secara umum, qubit yang dikawal
tak perlu berada di atas dan gate-gate ini tak perlu
bertindak pada qubit yang berjiran, bermaksud gate-gate ini boleh diregangkan melintasi
qubit-qubit lain yang ia tidak bertindak, dan kita akan nampak itu
berlaku dalam pelajaran-pelajaran akan datang.
Satu lagi perkara yang kita selalu lakukan bila menggunakan model quantum circuit adalah melihat operasi unitari sewenang-wenangnya
pada sebarang bilangan qubit
seolah-olah ia adalah gate tunggal seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Hanya dengan melukis segi empat tepat dengan label yang sesuai
dengan operasi unitari apa pun ia.
Dalam kes ini ia adalah
operasi unitari U.
Sudah tentu, kita tak tahu
apa U dari rajah ini, kita perlu anggap bahawa
U ditakrifkan entah bagaimana atau bahawa kita mempertimbangkan sebarang
operasi unitari U, mungkin. Ia boleh jadi contohnya bahawa
kita hanya mahu fikirkan tentang U seolah-olah ia adalah subrutin
demi kejelasan.
Kita juga guna notasi ini
yang kamu lihat di sini untuk operasi controlled U
di mana qubit kawalan ditunjukkan oleh bulatan pepejal
sama seperti yang kita ada sebelum ini.
Jadi itu adalah pengenalan ringkas
kepada model quantum circuit. Dan seperti yang saya kata sebelum ini, kita akan nampak banyak lagi
contoh quantum circuit
bila kita teruskan dalam siri ini.
Dalam bahagian pelajaran seterusnya, kita akan
tengok hasil darab dalam, orthormonaliti dan unjuran, yang merupakan konsep-konsep yang sangat penting
dalam maklumat dan pengiraan kuantum.
Kita akan mulakan dengan hasil darab dalam.
Ingat bahawa bila kita
guna notasi Dirac, Ket adalah vektor lajur
dan Bra adalah vektor baris,
dan khususnya vektor
Bra yang sepadan dengan vektor lajur yang diberikan adalah transpos konjugat
daripada vektor lajur itu.
Jadi untuk vektor ini di sini, kita peroleh vektor Bra yang sepadan dengan mentranspos vektor
seolah-olah ia adalah matriks,
yang bermaksud meletakkannya pada sisinya dan kemudian mengambil konjugat kompleks bagi setiap entri.
Sekarang, anggaplah kita ada dua Ket dengan bilangan entri yang sama seperti ini.
Kalau kita bentuk kurungan ini di sini, yang hanya bermaksud bahawa
kita mengambil hasil darab Bra dan Ket,
seolah-olah ia adalah matriks,
maka kita memperoleh ungkapan ini
yang kamu lihat di sini, yang merupakan skalar, atau dengan kata lain nombor kompleks.
Nilai ini dipanggil hasil darab dalam
dua vektor ini.
Kamu juga boleh fikirkan tentang hasil darab dalam dari segi vektor dalam
bentuk yang kamu lihat di sini di mana vektor dinyatakan
sebagai gabungan linear
daripada vektor asas standard.
Hasil darab dalam vektor-vektor ini ditakrifkan dengan cara yang sama seperti
sebelumnya, Bra Psi kali Ket Phi yang boleh kita nyatakan
sebagai hasil darab seperti ini.
Dan kalau kita kira dan permudahkan, kita tinggal dengan ungkapan ini di sini untuk hasil darab dalam, yang adalah analogous kepada apa yang kita ada sebelum ini,
kecuali kali ini kita
mengambil jumlah atas elemen dalam set keadaan klasik kita, yang adalah sigma dalam kes ini.
Ini adalah contoh yang bertujuan untuk memberi kamu gambaran geometri tentang
macam mana hasil darab dalam berfungsi.
Di sini saya telah melukis bulatan
dalam ruang dua dimensi yang sepadan dengan qubit, dan selagi kita hadkan perhatian kita
kepada vektor yang mempunyai entri nombor nyata, kita boleh lukiskannya sebagai titik pada satah ini.
WEBVTT
Jom ambil Phi sebagai
vektor ini di sini.
Ia adalah vektor unit, yang boleh kita lihat dengan
mengira norma Euclidean dan itulah yang diwakili bulatan ini,
ia adalah semua vektor unit
yang mempunyai entri nombor nyata.
Jom juga katakan Psi adalah
vektor ini di sini, yang sekali lagi juga merupakan vektor unit.
Ia sebenarnya keadaan minus, tapi di sini kita hanya memanggilnya Psi.
Kalau kita kira hasil darab dalam
dua vektor ini, kita dapat satu tolak punca tiga di atas dua kali punca dua,
yang kebetulan kira-kira -1/4.
Nilai hasil darab dalam ini sama dengan kosinus sudut
antara dua vektor, yang boleh kamu lihat di sini dalam rajah.
Itu adalah sesuatu yang
umumnya benar untuk vektor unit. Kalau kita ada dua vektor unit dan kedua-duanya mempunyai entri nombor nyata,
maka hasil darab dalam antara mereka sama dengan kosinus
sudut antara mereka.
Khususnya, kalau hasil darab dalam
sama dengan sifar, seperti dalam contoh ini, di mana kita tukar Psi menjadi
keadaan ini di sini,
maka dua vektor mesti
berada pada sudut 90 darjah antara satu sama lain.
Ini semua digeneralisasi kepada
vektor dalam mana-mana dimensi, by the way, selagi entri
adalah nombor nyata, ia bukan hanya untuk vektor dua dimensi.
Kalau kita ada entri nombor kompleks, gambar itu tidak benar-benar
berfungsi lagi, tetapi bagaimanapun, hasil darab dalam adalah sama berguna seperti yang akan kita lihat.
Hasil darab dalam mempunyai beberapa
sifat yang sangat penting dan kita akan ambil beberapa ketika untuk perhatikan beberapa sifat tersebut sekarang.
Pertama adalah hubungan
antara hasil darab dalam dan norma Euclidean.
Kalau kita ambil hasil darab dalam
mana-mana vektor dengan dirinya sendiri, kita dapat norma Euclidean kuasa dua.
Jadi kita boleh alternatifnya kata bahawa norma Euclidean vektor sama dengan punca kuasa dua hasil darab dalam
vektor itu dengan dirinya sendiri. Ini bukan kebetulan, ini
adalah hubungan asas, dan di sini kita boleh lihat bahawa kalau kita tak ada
konjugat kompleks dalam definisi hasil darab dalam, maka formula ini
tidak akan benar lagi, dan kita tidak akan ada konsep yang begitu berguna
dengan hubungan asas ini
kepada norma Euclidean.
Seterusnya, hasil darab dalam
adalah konjugat simetri, yang bermaksud bahawa kalau kita tukar
urutan dua argumen, maka nilai yang kita dapat untuk
hasil darab dalam dikonjugat.
Itu dinyatakan oleh
persamaan ini di sini dan agak mudah untuk lihat kenapa ini berlaku untuk dua ungkapan ini
untuk hasil darab dalam dua vektor dalam dua kemungkinan urutan.
Hasil darab dalam adalah linear
dalam argumen kedua. Khususnya, kalau kita takrifkan vektor Phi sebagai ini gabungan linear dua vektor,
Phi satu dan Phi dua, maka hasil darab dalam
mana-mana vektor Psi dengan Phi adalah gabungan linear yang sama
daripada dua hasil darab dalam,
dan ini mengikut secara langsung dari fakta bahawa pendaraban matriks adalah linear.
Dan kita juga ada bahawa hasil darab dalam
adalah konjugat linear dalam argumen pertama, yang boleh kamu lihat dinyatakan di sini.
Kalau Psi adalah ini gabungan linear vektor, maka kalau kita ambil hasil darab dalam
Psi dan Phi,
maka Bra Psi menjadi vektor ini yang kita lihat di sini di mana kita mengambil konjugat kompleks beta satu dan beta dua,
dan jadi ini adalah hasilnya dan itulah yang dimaksudkan
dengan kelinearan konjugat.
Dan sifat terakhir hasil darab dalam yang saya nak sebut adalah
ketaksamaan Cauchy-Schwarz yang sangat berguna.
Untuk mana-mana dua vektor, Psi dan Phi, nilai mutlak hasil darab dalam tidak pernah boleh lebih besar daripada
hasil darab norma Euclidean
dua vektor. Dan lebih-lebih lagi, satu-satunya cara bahawa kedua-dua
belah ketaksamaan boleh sama adalah jika dua
vektor adalah bergantung secara linear,
yang bermaksud bahawa salah satu daripada mereka sama dengan beberapa skalar kali yang lain.
Ini sebenarnya adalah salah satu
ketaksamaan yang paling banyak digunakan dalam semua matematik dan
kita gunakannya berulang kali bila kita bercakap tentang
maklumat kuantum,
jadi ia sangat baik untuk diketahui.
Seterusnya, kita akan bincangkan
konsep ortogonaliti dan orthormonaliti yang berkaitan dengan hasil darab dalam
dan khususnya, dengan
hasil darab dalam vektor yang sama dengan sifar.
Untuk lebih tepat, kalau kita ada
dua vektor, Psi dan Phi, kita kata ia ortogon
jika hasil darab dalam mereka
sama dengan sifar. Dan cara kita boleh fikirkan
tentang vektor ortogon secara intuitif adalah bahawa ia berada
pada sudut tepat antara satu sama lain,
atau alternatifnya, bahawa ia
berserenjang antara satu sama lain.
Orang kadang-kadang guna istilah ortogon untuk merujuk kepada perkara yang tidak ada kena mengena antara satu sama lain, seperti mengatakan bahawa satu isu
adalah ortogon kepada yang lain,
tapi itu jelas agak tidak formal dan tidak benar-benar bermakna
dalam erti kata matematik, tapi hubungannya jelas kalau kamu fikirkan tentang vektor ortogon sebagai menunjuk
bukan dalam arah yang bertentangan, tapi dalam arah yang sama sekali berbeza seperti utara berbanding barat contohnya.
Kalau kita ada satu set vektor, kita kata bahawa set itu adalah set ortogon jika mana-mana dua vektor yang berbeza
dipilih dari set itu
semestinya ortogon antara satu sama lain, yang boleh kita nyatakan
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
Set orthormonormal adalah
hanya set ortogon vektor unit.
WEBVTT
Set orthormonormal adalah
hanya set ortogon vektor unit.
Vektor dalam set ortogon
tak semestinya perlu menjadi vektor unit, dan sebenarnya kamu boleh
ada vektor sifar
sebagai elemen set ortogon, tapi dalam set orthormonormal, setiap vektor mesti menjadi vektor unit
sebagai tambahan kepada
keperluan bahawa set itu adalah set ortogon.
Memandangkan apa yang kita tahu tentang hubungan antara hasil darab dalam
dan norma Euclidean, kita boleh nyatakan syarat ini dengan ringkas
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dan akhirnya, asas orthormonormal hanyalah set orthormonormal
yang membentuk asas untuk ruang vektor apa pun
yang kita bercakap tentangnya.
Contohnya, kalau kita ambil mana-mana
set keadaan klasik sigma dan kita fikirkan tentang set
semua vektor asas standard,
kita nampak bahawa ini adalah set orthormonormal dan sebenarnya ia adalah asas orthormonormal untuk ruang semua vektor yang entri-entrinya sepadan dengan
set keadaan klasik sigma ini.
Ini semua adalah vektor unit dan
ia ortogon berpasangan, jadi ia adalah set orthormonormal.
dan kerana ia juga asas, kita ada bahawa ia adalah asas orthormonormal.
Set orthormonormal adalah
sentiasa bebas secara linear by the way, jadi bila sahaja kamu
ada set orthormonormal, ia akan sentiasa menjadi asas orthormonormal bagi beberapa subruang,
tapi dalam kes ini, kita ada asas untuk keseluruhan ruang yang kita sedang bekerja dengannya.
Contoh lain adalah set
yang mengandungi Ket+ dan Ket-.
Dua vektor ini adalah ortogon, hasil darab dalam mereka sama dengan sifar.
dan ia adalah kedua-dua vektor unit dan ia merangkumi
ruang dua dimensi vektor yang sepadan dengan qubit tunggal, jadi ia membentuk asas orthormonormal
untuk ruang itu.
Contoh lain adalah asas Bell, yang merupakan asas orthormonormal untuk ruang semua
vektor empat dimensi yang sepadan dengan dua qubit.
Set yang mengandungi Ket 0
dan Ket+ sebaliknya, bukan set ortogon kerana hasil darab dalam antara
vektor-vektor ini adalah bukan sifar.
Ia adalah kedua-dua vektor unit dan ini adalah asas untuk ruang vektor yang sepadan dengan qubit, tapi kita tidak ada ortogonaliti.
Ini adalah fakta berguna tentang set orthormonormal yang akan kita gunakan dari semasa ke semasa.
Anggaplah kita ada beberapa
set orthormonormal vektor, khususnya, jom anggap
kita ada vektor M dalam set ini, Psi satu hingga Psi M,
di mana kita mengandaikan bahawa vektor-vektor ini diambil dari beberapa
ruang vektor N dimensi, atau dengan kata lain, setiap
vektor mempunyai entri M.
Seperti yang saya dah sebut, set orthormonormal adalah sentiasa
bebas secara linear, jadi ia tak mungkin bahawa M lebih besar daripada N,
tapi boleh jadi M lebih kecil daripada N, dan itulah kes yang
kita minati.
Dan apa yang fakta nyatakan adalah
bahawa kalau M lebih kecil daripada N, maka ia sentiasa mungkin
untuk menambah vektor-vektor tambahan
kepada set yang kita mulakan untuk mendapatkan
asas orthormonormal untuk ruang kita.
Untuk lebih tepat, mesti
semestinya wujud vektor Psi M+1 hingga Psi N supaya keseluruhan koleksi
membentuk asas orthormonormal.
Jadi kamu tidak boleh terkepung,
dalam erti kata, dengan entah bagaimana memilih
set orthormonormal vektor yang tidak boleh dilanjutkan untuk
membentuk asas orthormonormal.
Kadang-kadang kamu boleh tengok sahaja
set yang kamu mulakan dan fikirkan macam mana untuk melanjutkannya untuk membentuk asas orthormonormal, tapi alternatif yang sentiasa berfungsi
adalah menggunakan prosedur yang dikenali sebagai proses
orthormonalisasi Gram-Schmidt untuk membina vektor-vektor ini.
Saya tidak akan terangkan
prosedur itu dalam pelajaran ini atau dalam siri ini kerana butiran spesifiknya tidak
begitu penting untuk kita, tapi sudah tentu kamu boleh mencarinya kalau kamu ingin tahu.
Ia adalah sesuatu yang boleh
dilakukan oleh komputer sekiranya itu relevan, jadi
tiada kreativiti yang terlibat, ia hanya prosedur mekanikal.
Salah satu sebab kenapa ini
adalah fakta yang begitu berguna adalah berkaitan dengan hubungan rapat yang wujud antara asas orthormonormal
dan matriks unitari.
Khususnya, untuk mana-mana matriks persegi U, tiga syarat yang kamu lihat di sini adalah sentiasa setara,
bermaksud bahawa ia sama ada
semua benar atau semua salah.
Syarat pertama mengatakan
bahawa U adalah matriks unitari, yang bermaksud bahawa kedua-dua U dagger kali U dan U kali U dagger adalah kedua-duanya
sama dengan matriks identiti.
Syarat kedua
mengatakan bahawa baris-baris U membentuk asas orthormonormal
dan syarat ketiga mengatakan bahawa lajur-lajur U
membentuk asas orthormonormal.
Sebenarnya tidak terlalu sukar
untuk lihat kenapa kesetaraan ini adalah benar.
Hanya untuk memudahkan, jom tengok matriks tiga kali tiga U seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, di mana entri-entrinya boleh menjadi mana-mana
nombor kompleks yang kamu suka.
Di sini di sebelah kiri saya telah menulis U transpos konjugat
hanya untuk kemudahan.
Kalau kita bentuk tiga vektor
dari lajur-lajur U, yang di sini dinamakan Psi
satu, Psi dua dan Psi tiga, maka kalau kita ambil
hasil darab U dagger dan U,
kamu boleh periksa bahawa setiap
entri hasil darab diberikan oleh hasil darab dalam vektor-vektor seperti yang kita lihat di sini dalam corak ini.
Dan sekarang bila kamu fikirkan tentang syarat bahawa U adalah unitari, yang setara dengan matriks ini sama dengan matriks identiti,
kamu nampak bahawa ia setara
dengan tiga vektor yang membentuk set orthormonormal.
Entri-entri pepenjuru semuanya
perlu sama dengan satu, jadi ini semestinya vektor unit, dan entri-entri di luar pepenjuru perlu sifar,
jadi ia adalah set ortogon vektor.
WEBVTT
Jadi U menjadi unitari adalah setara dengan lajur-lajur yang membentuk set orthormonormal,
Dan itu mesti menjadi asas kerana bilangan vektor dalam set, yang adalah tiga dalam kes ini, bersetuju dengan dimensi ruang
yang kita sedang bekerja dengannya. Kamu boleh ikuti argumen yang sama untuk baris-baris dan bukannya lajur-lajur untuk menyimpulkan bahawa U menjadi
unitari adalah setara
dengan baris-baris yang membentuk asas orthormonormal.
Ia tidak berfungsi dengan baik kerana kita perlu membuat pelarasan untuk mendapatkan konjugat kompleks
untuk berfungsi dengan cara yang betul, tapi ideanya adalah sama.
Cara alternatif untuk melakukannya, yang agak mudah, adalah untuk membuktikan bahawa matriks adalah unitari jika dan hanya jika transposnya adalah unitari.
Dan di sini saya memang bermaksud transpos dan bukan transpos konjugat.
Ia agak remeh dari
definisi matriks unitari, bahawa transpos konjugat
mana-mana matriks unitari adalah unitari,
tapi ia juga berlaku bahawa transpos mana-mana matriks unitari adalah unitari.
Bagaimanapun, kita ada
kesetaraan antara tiga syarat ini pada mana-mana matriks persegi U, dan kita boleh menggabungkan kesetaraan ini
dengan fakta tentang
melanjutkan set orthormonormal untuk membentuk asas orthormonormal untuk mendapatkan matriks unitari
yang melakukan perkara-perkara menarik
atau memenuhi pelbagai keperluan yang mungkin kita hadapi.
Khususnya bila sahaja kita
ada set orthormonormal M vektor, akan sentiasa wujud matriks unitari U
yang M lajur pertamanya adalah vektor-vektor dari set orthormonormal itu.
Lajur-lajur yang tinggal
boleh sentiasa diisi supaya kita memperoleh matriks unitari dengan memilihnya supaya lajur-lajur membentuk
asas orthormonormal. Ini akan menjadi fakta yang agak
berguna untuk kita ada.
Dan satu lagi topik untuk
bahagian pelajaran ini adalah konsep unjuran.
Matriks persegi Pi dikatakan
sebagai unjuran atau matriks unjuran jika dua sifat yang
disenaraikan di sini adalah kedua-duanya benar.
Ini adalah Pi huruf besar by the way, ia adalah pilihan huruf yang agak tipikal yang digunakan untuk menandakan unjuran.
Kita sering memberi nama tipikal seperti ini kepada objek seperti matriks hanya untuk memudahkan pengecaman dan mengekalkan kejelasan,
tapi kamu boleh guna nama apa pun yang kamu suka. Bagaimanapun, syarat pertama adalah bahawa Pi sama dengan transpos konjugat sendiri.
Secara umum, bila kita ada matriks yang sama dengan
transpos konjugat sendiri, kita kata ia adalah matriks Hermitian.
Jadi syarat pertama boleh dinyatakan secara alternatif sebagai Pi adalah Hermitian.
Syarat kedua adalah
bahawa kalau kita kuasadua Pi, bermaksud kita darab Pi
dengan dirinya sendiri, kita dapat Pi lagi.
Jadi mengkuasadua Pi tidak melakukan apa-apa padanya.
Idea unjuran
secara intuitif adalah bahawa ia adalah serupa dalam
semangat dengan mengunjurkan imej ke skrin atau menjatuhkan
garis serenjang ke garis
contohnya. Bila kamu darab
vektor dengan unjuran, apa yang kamu lakukan adalah dalam erti kata tertentu
membiarkan sebahagian daripadanya sahaja
dan mensifarkan bakinya.
Jadi kalau kamu gunakan
unjuran kali kedua, ia tidak melakukan apa-apa kerana
kamu dah menyifarkan bahagian yang unjuran sifarkan.
Contoh unjuran
adalah matriks ini di sini untuk mana-mana pilihan vektor unit Psi.
Kita boleh periksa bahawa ia memenuhi
syarat yang diperlukan satu demi satu.
Untuk yang pertama, kita kira
transpos konjugat dan ini adalah transpos konjugat
hasil darab.
Dan jadi kita boleh guna formula ini di sini untuk transpos konjugat
hasil darab untuk membantu kita.
Apa yang kamu dapat adalah hasil darab
transpos konjugat, tapi urutannya terbalik.
Itu berlaku kerana
bahagian transpos.
Jadi kalau kita gunakan formula itu, kita memperoleh kesetaraan ini di sini dan kita kemudiannya boleh permudahkan untuk
mendapatkan kembali matriks asal.
Perhatikan by the way, bahawa kita tidak menggunakan fakta
bahawa Psi adalah vektor unit.
Jadi sebenarnya, matriks ini adalah
Hermitian untuk mana-mana vektor Psi, bukan hanya untuk vektor unit.
Dan untuk yang kedua, kita kuasadua Pi dan kita memperoleh
ungkapan ini di sini dan ia sama dengan matriks asal kali ini
kerana Psi adalah vektor unit, jadi hasil darab dalam
ini di sini sama dengan satu dan itulah di mana andaian
bahawa Psi adalah vektor unit
berperanan.
Kita boleh generalisasi contoh ini dan mulakan dengan set orthormonormal.
Dan kalau kita bentuk matriks ini di sini, di mana kita menjumlahkan unjuran yang sepadan dengan vektor-vektor individu, maka kita memperoleh unjuran.
Di sini pada skrin, kamu boleh lihat pengiraan yang mendedahkan itu dan saya akan biarkan kamu
untuk memeriksanya kalau kamu mahu.
Dan seperti yang serupa
dengan contoh pertama, adalah syarat kedua di mana orthormonaliti
set digunakan.
Apa yang unjuran ini lakukan kalau
kamu darabnya dengan vektor, adalah mengunjurkan vektor itu ke subruang yang dicakupi oleh set vektor ini,
yang secara abstrak adalah
seperti menjatuhkan garis serenjang ke subruang itu, dan setelah
kamu berada dalam subruang itu, unjuran tidak melakukan apa-apa.
Jadi matriks seperti ini adalah
contoh unjuran, dan sekarang sebenarnya kita dah kehabisan
semua kemungkinan.
Setiap matriks unjuran mengambil bentuk ini untuk beberapa pilihan set orthormonormal.
Matriks sifar adalah unjuran, jadi kita memang perlu
pastikan kita sertakan itu kalau kita mahu mendapat setiap unjuran.
WEBVTT
Jadi untuk jelaskan tentang ini, kita membenarkan
kemungkinan bahawa M sama dengan sifar dan itu memberi kita jumlah kosong,
yang boleh kita tafsirkan sebagai matriks sifar.
Sekarang bahawa kita ada
konsep unjuran, kita boleh takrifkan kelas pengukuran kuantum yang lebih umum
yang dikenali sebagai pengukuran projektif.
Ini bukan konsep yang paling umum
tentang pengukuran, tapi ia adalah jauh lebih umum daripada pengukuran asas standard
dan ia akan sangat
membantu untuk memasukkannya ke dalam penerangan kita
tentang maklumat kuantum.
Pengukuran projektif ditakrifkan oleh mana-mana set unjuran
yang memenuhi syarat yang kamu lihat di sini, yang adalah bahawa unjuran-unjuran
menjumlahkan kepada matriks identiti.
Di sini M boleh menjadi mana-mana
integer positif yang kamu suka selagi ini semua adalah unjuran dan syarat ini adalah benar,
koleksi itu mentakrifkan
pengukuran projektif.
Pengukuran yang diterangkan
oleh koleksi seperti itu berfungsi seperti berikut bila kamu
mengukur mana-mana keadaan kuantum Psi.
Pertama kamu mendapat hasil
antara satu dan M, di mana M adalah bilangan unjuran.
Untuk setiap hasil yang mungkin, K, kebarangkalian untuk mendapat hasil itu adalah norma Euclidean
kuasa dua vektor yang kamu dapat
dengan mendarab S dengan Pi
K, unjuran Kth.
Kita juga boleh tulis
kuantiti ini seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kesetaraan ini datang dari hubungan antara norma Euclidean
dan hasil darab dalam bersama-sama dengan fakta
bahawa Pi K adalah unjuran.
Dari bentuk kedua, bersama-sama dengan syarat yang kita ada pada unjuran-unjuran ini, kita boleh lihat dengan serta-merta, oleh kelinearan, bahawa kebarangkalian kita
akan sentiasa menjumlahkan kepada satu,
dengan ingatan bahawa Psi
mesti menjadi vektor unit.
Dan kedua, dengan mengandaikan bahawa
kita mendapat hasil, K, keadaan sistem
runtuh kepada keadaan kuantum yang kita dapat dengan menormalkan apa jua
vektor yang kita dapat dengan mengunjurkan.
Kita akan tengok beberapa
contoh dalam sebentar, tapi sebelum kita buat itu, izinkan saya menyebut bahawa kita sebenarnya tidak perlu
untuk menomborkan kemungkinan
hasil dari satu hingga M. Kita boleh pilih nama atau simbol apa pun yang kita mahu untuk hasil-hasil.
Khususnya, kalau kita ada koleksi unjuran yang dilabel dengan simbol
dari beberapa set gamma katakanlah,
dan ia memenuhi
syarat yang sama seperti sebelumnya, yang adalah bahawa ia menjumlahkan
kepada matriks identiti, maka kita ada pengukuran projektif
yang berfungsi dengan cara yang sama persis seperti sebelumnya.
Satu-satunya perbezaan di sini adalah bahawa kita membenarkan
hasil pengukuran menjadi elemen set gamma ini berbanding dengan integer dari satu hingga M.
Untuk contoh pertama kita tentang
pengukuran projektif, jom perhatikan bahawa
pengukuran asas standard adalah pengukuran projektif.
Dalam kes ini set
hasil pengukuran adalah sama dengan set keadaan klasik apa pun sistem yang sedang diukur.
Dan set unjuran
yang menerangkan pengukuran adalah koleksi ini di sini, dengan mengandaikan bahawa sigma adalah
set keadaan klasik
sistem kita. Ini semua adalah unjuran
dan kalau kita menjumlahkannya, kita mendapat matriks identiti, jadi ia adalah pengukuran projektif yang sah
Untuk lihat macam mana ini berfungsi
dengan lebih terperinci sedikit, jom anggap bahawa kita
ada beberapa keadaan sewenang-wenangnya yang ditulis dalam bentuk
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kebarangkalian untuk
pengukuran menghasilkan hasil A, mengikut penerangan
dari sebentar tadi, adalah nilai ini di sini,
yang sama dengan
nilai mutlak kuasa dua entri yang sepadan
vektor Psi, yang adalah apa yang kita jangka.
Bersyarat pada hasil menjadi A, keadaan sistem menjadi ini, sekali lagi, mengikut
penerangan dari sebentar tadi.
Kalau kita permudahkan, kita tidak
mendapat keadaan yang kita jangkakan, iaitu Ket A.
Sebaliknya kita mendapat Ket A
didarab dengan skalar, dan khususnya, ini adalah skalar yang mempunyai
nilai mutlak sama dengan satu,
jadi ia adalah nombor kompleks
pada bulatan unit.
Ini dipanggil fasa global dan kita akan bincangkan fasa global tidak lama lagi, tapi buat sekarang secara ringkasnya, keadaan ini
adalah setara dengan Ket A.
Fasa global ini tidak
mempunyai sebarang kepentingan langsung dan kita akan lihat kenapa
bila kita sampai ke perbincangan fasa global.
Jadi (tidak jelas) isu fasa global ini, yang akan kita bincangkan dalam sebentar, kita nampak bahawa pengukuran asas standard
sebenarnya adalah pengukuran projektif. Untuk contoh lain, yang sebenarnya adalah sambungan
contoh sebelumnya,
kalau kita lakukan pengukuran asas standard
pada sistem X dan kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada sistem Y, sama seperti yang kita bincangkan
dalam pelajaran sebelumnya,
ia adalah setara sepenuhnya
dengan mengukur sistem X, Y.
Dengan pengukuran projektif
ini di sini.
Kita ada unjuran-unjuran yang sepadan dengan keadaan klasik X dan kita men-tensor dengan identiti pada Y
yang mencerminkan fakta bahawa
kita tidak melakukan apa-apa pada Y.
Penerangan tentang macam mana
pengukuran projektif berfungsi secara umum memberitahu kita
apa yang berlaku dalam contoh ini, dan saya akan biarkan kamu untuk
periksa bahawa ini sebenarnya
adalah setara sepenuhnya dengan apa yang kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya.
Ini semua sangat bagus kerana penerangan pengukuran projektif ini lebih bersih dalam satu cara dan kita nampak bahawa ia sesuai ke dalam
gambaran yang lebih umum ini.
WEBVTT
Ini adalah satu lagi contoh
pengukuran projektif.
Ini adalah pengukuran dua qubit.
Untuk pengukuran ini
kita ada dua unjuran dan oleh itu, dua kemungkinan
hasil iaitu sifar dan satu.
Unjuran-unjuran ditakrifkan
dari segi keadaan Bell seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Unjuran pertama adalah
ke atas ruang yang dicakupi oleh tiga keadaan Bell simetri dan unjuran kedua adalah
ke atas ruang satu dimensi
yang dicakupi oleh keadaan Psi-, yang merupakan yang anti-simetri, atau dengan kata lain yang
mendapat didarab
dengan tanda tolak kalau kita
lakukan operasi swap pada dua qubit.
Kita akan nampak kemudian dalam siri ini kenapa ini adalah pengukuran yang menarik.
Buat sekarang, ia hanya contoh
yang berkaitan dengan sesuatu yang kita dah lihat sebelum ini,
iaitu asas Bell.
Satu nota akhir tentang pengukuran projektif adalah bahawa bila sahaja kamu ada
pengukuran projektif, kamu sentiasa boleh laksanakan pengukuran itu
menggunakan operasi unitari dan
pengukuran asas standard.
Untuk contoh pengukuran ini, sebagai contoh, kita boleh bina quantum circuit yang melaksanakan pengukuran
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita bayangkan bahawa dua
qubit atas adalah qubit yang kita ukur dengan
pengukuran projektif ini dan apa yang boleh kita lakukan adalah
perkenalkan qubit baru
yang bermula diinisialisasi
kepada keadaan sifar. Kita lakukan Hadamard gate
diikuti oleh Fredkin gate, diikuti oleh satu lagi Hadamard gate,
dan kalau kita ukur qubit bawah ini menggunakan pengukuran asas standard, kesannya akan sama persis seperti kalau kita mengukur dua qubit atas
dengan pengukuran projektif
dari contoh ini.
Kita akan mendapat kebarangkalian yang sama persis untuk dua hasil dan kesan pengukuran pada dua qubit atas
akan sama juga.
Itu tidak jelas langsung. Analisis diperlukan untuk lihat itu dan analisis itu tidak ditunjukkan di sini.
Seperti yang saya dah cadangkan, kita akan tengok lebih teliti
pengukuran tertentu ini dalam pelajaran kemudian dan buat sekarang
ia hanya dimaksudkan sebagai contoh.
Perkara penting untuk dibawa pergi adalah bahawa sesuatu seperti
ini sentiasa mungkin untuk mana-mana pengukuran projektif, jadi kita tidak benar-benar mendapat
sebarang keupayaan tambahan
dengan memperkenalkan pengukuran projektif, tapi ia adalah konsep yang sangat berguna dan kita akan sering bercakap tentang pengukuran projektif
bila kita teruskan dalam siri. Bahagian terakhir pelajaran ini adalah tentang beberapa had penting
maklumat kuantum
dan apa yang boleh kita buat dengan quantum circuit.
Had pertama, yang mungkin bukan begitu banyak had seperti ia adalah kemerosotan, berkaitan dengan isu fasa global
yang saya sebut sebentar tadi. Ini adalah definisi apa yang kita maksudkan bila kita merujuk kepada fasa global.
Kalau kita ada dua vektor keadaan kuantum, Psi dan Phi, supaya salah satu daripadanya sama dengan yang lain didarab dengan beberapa nombor kompleks alpha,
maka kita kata bahawa keadaan-keadaan
berbeza dengan fasa global atau alternatifnya bahawa ia setara sehingga fasa global.
Perhatikan bahawa kerana vektor keadaan kuantum mempunyai norma Euclidean sama dengan satu, satu-satunya cara persamaan ini mungkin benar
adalah kalau nilai mutlak
nombor kompleks ini sama dengan satu, jadi alpha
mesti terletak pada bulatan unit.
Jom bayangkan kita ada
dua keadaan kuantum seperti ini yang berbeza dengan fasa global dan anggap bahawa kita mengukur keadaan Phi
dengan pengukuran asas standard.
Kebarangkalian untuk mendapat mana-mana hasil A diberikan oleh ungkapan ini di sini, dan kalau kita gantikan
alpha kali Psi untuk Phi,
yang boleh kita lakukan kerana kita
mengandaikan bahawa ia adalah sama, kita memperoleh kebarangkalian ini.
Dan kalau kita permudahkan menggunakan fakta bahawa alpha terletak dalam
bulatan unit kompleks, kita memperoleh kebarangkalian ini.
Ingat bahawa ini adalah kebarangkalian bahawa mengukur Phi memberi hasil A, tapi sekarang kita nampak bahawa
ini adalah sama persis dengan kebarangkalian bahawa mengukur
Psi memberi hasil A,
jadi tidak ada
perbezaan langsung pun dalam kebarangkalian hasil-hasil berbeza untuk dua keadaan.
Argumen yang serupa memberitahu kita secara lebih umum bahawa untuk mana-mana pengukuran projektif, kebarangkalian adalah sekali lagi sama.
Jadi dengan mengukur kita tidak boleh
membezakan antara dua keadaan yang
berbeza dengan fasa global, walaupun dalam erti kata statistik.
Akhirnya, kalau kita gunakan mana-mana operasi unitari
kepada keadaan Phi, maka sekali lagi dengan menggantikan, apa yang kita akan dapat adalah tepat
nombor kompleks alpha yang sama
didarab dengan apa jua yang kita akan dapat dengan menggunakan operasi unitari yang sama
kepada keadaan, Psi.
Jadi dua keadaan masih
berbeza dengan fasa global.
Kesimpulannya adalah bahawa dua keadaan adalah sama sekali tidak dapat dibezakan, jadi tidak ada benar-benar perbezaan antara mereka langsung
dari segi apa yang kita mungkin
pelajari tentang mereka dari melakukan operasi unitari
dan pengukuran dan atas sebab ini,
kita menganggap dua
keadaan ini sebagai setara atau kalau kamu suka, bahawa ini hanya dua kemungkinan berbeza
perwakilan vektor daripada
keadaan kuantum yang sama.
Seperti yang saya kata pada
permulaan perbincangan, ia pada dasarnya kemerosotan
dalam cara keadaan kuantum diterangkan oleh vektor keadaan kuantum.
Bagaimanapun, apa yang ini bermaksud adalah bahawa kita boleh
mengabaikan fasa global sama seperti yang kita buat dengan berkesan bila kita menerangkan pengukuran asas standard
WEBVTT
sebagai pengukuran projektif. By the way, kemerosotan ini hanya berlaku dalam penerangan ringkas
maklumat kuantum.
Bila kita menerangkan keadaan kuantum
menggunakan matriks ketumpatan, seperti yang akan kita lakukan dalam
unit ketiga siri ini, kita akan ada perwakilan matriks yang unik
untuk setiap keadaan kuantum. Isu fasa global
tidak timbul dalam penerangan umum
maklumat kuantum.
Ia adalah satu lagi aspek menarik
penerangan umum maklumat kuantum,
yang terus-terusan saya singgung, tapi bagaimanapun, fasa global tidak akan mengganggu kita
kerana kita boleh hanya gunakan
kebebasan kita untuk mengabaikannya.
Ini adalah contoh yang sangat ringkas
hanya untuk pastikan konsep fasa global adalah jelas.
Kalau kita ada keadaan minus, dan negatif satu kali keadaan minus, maka dua keadaan ini
berbeza dengan fasa global, dan khususnya kita ada
alpha sama dengan negatif satu.
Sebaliknya, kalau kita ada keadaan plus dan keadaan minus, maka kita tidak ada dua keadaan
yang berbeza dengan fasa global.
Ini adalah vektor ortogon, jadi ia bebas secara linear.
Untuk kata bahawa dua vektor keadaan kuantum berbeza dengan fasa global
adalah setara dengan kata bahawa vektor-vektor itu bergantung secara linear,
jadi sudah tentu vektor-vektor ini
tidak berbeza dengan fasa global.
Benar bahawa satu-satunya perbezaan adalah bahawa tanda tambah ini
bertukar menjadi tanda tolak ini, tapi itulah yang kita panggil perbezaan fasa relatif.
Itu berbeza dari fasa global kerana kita tidak
mendarab keseluruhan vektor dengan nombor kompleks.
Dan ini konsisten dengan fakta bahawa kita boleh membezakan antara keadaan-keadaan ini, khususnya, kalau kita
gunakan operasi Hadamard
dan kemudian mengukur, kita akan nampak sifar kalau
keadaannya adalah keadaan plus dan satu kalau keadaannya adalah keadaan minus.
Had seterusnya maklumat kuantum yang akan kita lihat dalam pelajaran ini
adalah teorem no-cloning.
Ini adalah satu pernyataan
teorem no-cloning dan pernyataan tertentu
teorem ini adalah agak konkrit dan spesifik,
yang akan memudahkan untuk bercakap tentangnya. Ada cara-cara lain yang lebih umum untuk merumuskan teorem no-cloning,
tapi kita akan fokus pada yang ini buat sekarang.
Kita anggap bahawa kita ada dua sistem X dan Y yang mempunyai set keadaan klasik yang sama.
yang terdiri daripada
integer dari sifar hingga D-1 di mana D adalah sekurang-kurangnya dua.
Tak begitu penting nama apa yang keadaan klasik ada, tapi dengan memilih nama-nama ini ia akan membantu untuk memudahkan.
Yang paling penting
di sini adalah bahawa ada sekurang-kurangnya dua keadaan klasik yang berbeza, jadi dengan kata lain, kita tidak risau tentang
kes remeh dan tidak menarik
di mana kita hanya ada satu keadaan klasik.
Apa yang teorem katakan adalah bahawa tidak ada operasi unitari U yang boleh kita gunakan pada X, Y supaya kalau kita inisialisasi
Y kepada keadaan sifar,
kita berkesan menyalin atau mengklon
keadaan kuantum sewenang-wenangnya X.
Kalau kita tengok ungkapan ini
di sini secara berasingan, apa yang ia katakan adalah bahawa untuk semua pilihan vektor keadaan kuantum Psi X,
menggunakan U pada Psi di-tensor
dengan keadaan sifar, memberi kita Psi tensor Psi, atau dengan kata lain dua
salinan bebas Psi,
jadi itulah yang bermaksud kalau kita boleh klon keadaan kuantum dan apa yang teorem katakan adalah bahawa ini tidak mungkin.
Kamu boleh fikirkan tentang ini
dari segi circuit dan apa yang teorem katakan adalah
bahawa kamu tidak akan pernah dapat mengemukakan gate atau circuit
yang berfungsi seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Di mana satu salinan keadaan Psi masuk bersama-sama dengan koleksi
qubit yang diinisialisasi dan dua salinan Psi dihasilkan.
Kamu boleh buat ini untuk pilihan-pilihan
keadaan Psi tertentu, tapi kamu tidak pernah boleh mengemukakan
circuit yang berfungsi cara ini untuk setiap keadaan kuantum Psi,
dan itulah yang teorem katakan.
Ia agak mudah untuk membuktikan
teorem ini, sebenarnya, ia pada dasarnya bergantung kepada fakta bahawa transformasi yang kita cari tidak adalah linear,
tapi operasi unitari adalah
linear, jadi ia memang tak boleh berfungsi.
Ini adalah argumen dengan lebih terperinci sedikit.
Anggaplah kita ada operasi unitari U yang mengklon keadaan asas standard
Ket 0 dan Ket satu.
Kita tahu bahawa keadaan klasik
sifar dan satu mesti tergolong dalam set keadaan klasik kita kerana D adalah sekurang-kurangnya dua.
Tapi ini bermaksud oleh kelinearan
bahawa kalau X berada dalam keadaan plus, yang boleh kita tulis seperti ini,
maka hasilnya adalah gabungan linear dua keadaan ini di sini.
Walau bagaimanapun, itu bukan tingkah laku yang betul. Keperluan pada U adalah bahawa
U mengklon keadaan plus,
yang bermaksud bahawa kita perlu
ada persamaan ini di sini yang dipenuhi.
Dua keadaan ini tidak
sama dan jadi ia tidak berfungsi dan itulah semua yang ada padanya.
Hanya beberapa catatan tambahan
tentang teorem no-cloning.
Pertama, pernyataan teorem no-cloning ini adalah mutlak dalam erti kata tertentu.
Ia hanya mengatakan bahawa operasi unitari U yang berfungsi tepat seperti
ini tidak wujud.
Jadi kamu mungkin tanya sama ada
atau tidak wujud operasi unitari U yang
melakukan ini secara anggaran berkenaan dengan beberapa cara untuk menerangkan
WEBVTT
penghampiran kepada pernyataan. Ada konsep-konsep penghampiran yang berbeza
yang mungkin diminati orang
dan kita akan nampak beberapa
daripadanya dalam unit ketiga siri, tapi untuk konsep-konsep penghampiran yang berbeza ini,
ada pernyataan kuantitatif
teorem no-cloning yang meletakkan had yang kukuh tentang seberapa baik kamu boleh mengklon secara anggaran.
Catatan kedua adalah bahawa menyalin atau mengklon keadaan asas standard memang
boleh dilakukan.
Sebagai contoh, Controlled NOT gate menyalin keadaan asas standard qubit.
Ini tidak bercanggah
dengan teorem no-cloning. Maksudnya adalah bahawa pengklonan dalam erti kata teorem no-cloning memerlukan
bahawa ini berfungsi bukan sahaja
untuk keadaan asas standard
tapi untuk semua keadaan.
Controlled NOT gate
sudah tentu tidak mengklon keadaan plus sebagai contoh.
Dan akhirnya, ada baiknya disebutkan bahawa ada juga teorem no-cloning untuk
keadaan kebarangkalian.
Ia hanya bukan sesuatu
yang orang bincangkan atau ambil berat.
Kalau seseorang secara rawak
memilih bit, sebagai contoh, untuk beberapa cara sewenang-wenangnya memberikan kebarangkalian kepada dua nilai dan
kemudian memberikan bit itu kepada kamu,
sudah tentu tidak ada cara untuk kamu mendapatkan dua sampel bebas
bit rawak itu.
Kamu memang tak tahu apa
kebarangkaliannya.
Kamu boleh salin bit itu sama seperti Controlled NOT
menyalin keadaan asas standard, tapi itu bukan perkara yang sama dengan mengklon keadaan kebarangkalian.
Kamu hanya tidak mempunyai maklumat yang cukup
untuk melakukan itu. Apa pun bit rawak yang diberikan kepada kamu tidak memberitahu kamu apa
kebarangkaliannya.
Ia hanya bit.
Kemustahilan mengklon
keadaan kebarangkalian mengikut daripada penaakulan yang sama seperti dalam tetapan kuantum.
Pengklonan adalah proses bukan linear, sedangkan operasi kebarangkalian, sama seperti operasi unitari, adalah linear.
Bagaimanapun, tidak mengejutkan
bahawa kita tidak boleh mengklon keadaan kebarangkalian dan entah bagaimana ia tidak semenarik fakta bahawa kita tidak boleh
mengklon keadaan kuantum,
tapi maksudnya hanyalah untuk perhatikan bahawa ini bukan fenomenon
kuantum yang unik.
Had terakhir
maklumat kuantum yang akan kita bincangkan dalam pelajaran ini adalah bahawa tidak mungkin untuk membezakan dengan sempurna
dua keadaan kuantum yang tidak ortogon.
Cara lain untuk menyatakannya
adalah bahawa kalau dua keadaan kuantum boleh dibezakan dengan sempurna, maka ia mesti ortogon.
Apa yang kita maksudkan bila kita merujuk kepada pembezaan sempurna dua keadaan kuantum, Psi dan Phi, adalah bahawa ada beberapa
cara untuk membezakannya
tanpa sebarang peluang ralat.
Dari segi model quantum circuit, kita boleh nyatakan ini seperti
yang kamu lihat di sini pada skrin.
Kita ada beberapa operasi unitari U, yang boleh dilaksanakan
sebagai quantum circuit atau kita boleh hanya fikirkan tentang U secara abstrak
sebagai operasi unitari
dan input paksa U mengambil sama ada keadaan Psi atau keadaan Phi
bersama-sama dengan beberapa qubit yang diinisialisasi, yang boleh kamu fikirkan sebagai qubit ruang kerja yang entah bagaimana membantu dalam
proses pembezaan ini.
Selepas U digunakan, qubit atas diukur berkenaan dengan pengukuran asas standard dan inilah bahagian pembezaan sempurna.
Kalau keadaan input adalah Psi, maka pengukuran mesti
memberi hasil sifar, 100% masa, dan kalau
keadaan input adalah Phi,
maka pengukuran mesti
memberi hasil satu, sekali lagi dengan peluang 100%.
Tak penting apa
keadaan qubit-qubit lain ini selepas U digunakan.
Yang penting hanyalah satu bit ini yang kita dapat dari pengukuran kerana itulah bit yang memberitahu kita keadaan mana dari dua keadaan yang kita mulakan.
Untuk sesetengah pilihan keadaan, Psi dan Phi, adalah mungkin untuk melakukan pembezaan sempurna seperti
ini dan untuk yang lain tidak.
Dan apa yang kita akan perhatikan adalah bahawa
kalau ia mungkin untuk melakukan ini, maka Psi dan Phi perlu menjadi keadaan ortogon
dan itu bermaksud kalau Phi dan
Psi tidak ortogon, kamu tidak boleh membezakannya dengan sempurna.
Jadi jom tengok kenapa pembezaan sempurna membayangkan ortogonaliti.
Kita akan mulakan dengan menulis dua persamaan yang menyatakan apa yang dua rajah ini nyatakan.
Kalau kita fikirkan tentang keadaan kuantum, kita dapat selepas menggunakan U pada
beberapa qubit yang diinisialisasi bersama-sama dengan keadaan Psi,
kita nampak bahawa ia perlu
ada bentuk ini di sini, di mana Pi sifar adalah beberapa vektor keadaan kuantum yang mewakili keadaan
semua qubit ini
kecuali yang atas. Kita tidak ada maklumat
tentang keadaan kuantum ini, Pi sifar, ia boleh jadi apa sahaja,
tapi kita tahu bahawa keseluruhan
keadaan perlu kelihatan seperti ini kerana itulah satu-satunya
cara bahawa pengukuran dijamin memberi
hasil sifar, 100% masa.
Dan kita ada persamaan yang analogous
untuk yang kedua.
Kali ini qubit atas
perlu berada dalam keadaan satu dan sama seperti Pi sifar, keadaan Pi satu boleh jadi apa sahaja.
Dan selain tidak mempunyai
maklumat tentang Pi satu, kita juga tidak tahu apa-apa
tentang hubungan antara Pi sifar dan Pi satu.
Buat sekarang kita tidak tahu, ini hanya dua
keadaan kuantum yang sewenang-wenangnya.
WEBVTT
Apa yang boleh kita buat seterusnya adalah
mendarab kedua-dua belah persamaan-persamaan ini pada
kedua-dua belah dengan U dagger, bermaksud transpos konjugat U.
Dan kalau kita buat itu, kita mendapat dua persamaan
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kita menggunakan fakta bahawa U dagger kali U adalah matriks identiti.
Jadi itulah kenapa kita tidak nampak U atau U dagger di sebelah kiri mana-mana persamaan.
Dan sekarang kita boleh pertimbangkan hasil darab dalam antara Psi dan Phi.
Ia sama dengan hasil darab dalam
Psi dan Phi didarab dengan hasil darab dalam
keadaan L sifar dengan dirinya sendiri
kerana hasil darab dalam
mana-mana keadaan dengan dirinya sendiri adalah satu dan itu termasuk keadaan L sifar.
Dan sekarang kalau kita tengok dua persamaan kita, kita nampak bahawa ungkapan ini di sini sama dengan hasil darab dalam vektor-vektor
yang diwakili oleh dua persamaan. Dan khususnya ia adalah hasil darab dalam antara sebelah kiri
dua persamaan ini.
Jadi kita boleh dengan sama mennyatakan hasil darab dalam ini sebagai hasil darab dalam vektor yang diwakili oleh sebelah kanan
dua persamaan ini,
kerana sebelah kiri sama dengan sebelah kanan untuk kedua-dua persamaan.
Jadi kita mendapat ungkapan ini di sini, yang merupakan hasil darab dalam
dua sebelah kanan persamaan atau sama,
ia adalah transpos konjugat yang pertama didarab dengan yang kedua.
U kali U dagger sama
dengan matriks identiti, kerana U adalah unitari dan jadi ia hilang.
Dan kita boleh permudahkan sedikit untuk mendapat hasil darab
daripada hasil darab dalam ini.
Sekarang ingat bahawa kita tidak tahu apa-apa tentang hubungan
antara Pi sifar dan Pi satu, jadi kita tidak tahu apa
hasil darab dalam mereka.
Itu adalah misteri kepada kita. Tapi apa pun ia, kita mendarabnya dengan hasil darab dalam Ket 0 dan Ket satu, yang adalah sifar.
Jadi hasil akhirnya adalah bahawa
kita memperoleh nilai sifar, tapi itulah yang kita nak tunjukkan, hasil darab dalam antara
Psi dan Phi adalah sama dengan sifar.
Jadi dua keadaan adalah ortogon.
Jadi jangan susah payah cuba
membezakan dengan sempurna dua keadaan kuantum yang tidak ortogon, kamu memang tak boleh buat.
Ada kebalikan kepada
pernyataan yang baru kita buktikan, yang adalah bahawa keadaan kuantum ortogon sentiasa boleh dibezakan dengan sempurna,
dan ini tidak terlalu sukar untuk
dilihat kalau kita menggunakan fakta yang saya sebutkan lebih awal dalam pelajaran.
Khususnya kalau Psi dan
Phi adalah keadaan ortogon, maka salah satu perkara yang boleh kita lakukan adalah memilih mana-mana matriks unitari U
yang dua lajur pertamanya
adalah dua keadaan itu.
Kita tahu bahawa sentiasa
mungkin untuk melakukan ini dan tidak penting
demi tugas ini bagaimana sebenarnya matriks unitari ini dipilih.
Yang penting hanyalah bahawa ini adalah dua lajur pertama.
Kita tidak memerlukan qubit tambahan. Kalau kita hanya gunakan U pada
dua keadaan yang mungkin, maka kita akan mendapat dua
kemungkinan hasil ini.
Dan kalau kita ukur qubit paling atas, yang ingat adalah qubit paling kanan, maka kita akan mendapat sifar atau satu
bergantung pada keadaan mana yang kita mulakan.
Alternatifnya, kita boleh pertimbangkan
pengukuran projektif dengan hasil sifar hingga satu
yang ditakrifkan seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dalam kes ini, pengukuran
sebenarnya hanya bergantung pada Psi.
Pengukuran ini membezakan dengan sempurna
Psi dari mana-mana keadaan yang ortogon kepada Psi.
Kalau kita ukur Psi berkenaan dengan pengukuran projektif ini, maka kita akan mendapat hasil
sifar dengan kebarangkalian satu seperti yang persamaan-persamaan ini tunjukkan.
Dan untuk mana-mana keadaan Phi
yang ortogon kepada Psi, kita akan mendapat hasil
satu dengan kebarangkalian satu.
Saya tidak akan melalui
butiran pengiraan-pengiraan ini, tapi kalau kamu berminat, saya galakkan kamu untuk melalui
butiran sendiri.
Dan itulah penghujung pelajaran tiga. Kita dah liputi banyak
bahan dalam pelajaran ini, termasuk quantum circuit,
hasil darab dalam dan orthormonaliti, unjuran dan pengukuran projektif, fakta bahawa fasa global tidak penting,
teorem no-cloning, dan fakta bahawa keadaan yang tidak ortogon tidak boleh dibezakan dengan sempurna sementara keadaan ortogon boleh.
Saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk
pelajaran keempat tidak lama lagi, yang merupakan pelajaran terakhir dalam
unit pertama siri.
Dalam pelajaran keempat, kita akan bincangkan tiga
contoh yang sangat penting, teleportasi, pengkodan superpejal,
dan ketaksamaan CHSH atau permainan CHSH seperti yang kadang-kadang diterangkan.
Selamat tinggal sehingga ketika itu,